Transcription: Samira Kwache
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Je voudrais commencer
mon propos par vous demander
quels sont les sentiments
qui vous ont habités
lorsque vous avez écouté
cette vidéo pour la première fois.
Comment vous êtes-vous sentis ?
Pardon ?
Réduite,
chosifiée,
marginalisée…
Et êtes-vous pour ou contre
cette affirmation ?
Pour ou contre ?
(Réactions du public)
Je vais trouver le juste milieu,
rassurez-vous,
aujourd’hui, on ne va pas chercher
qui est pour ou contre,
ou fâché, ou content
par cette affirmation.
Aujourd’hui, on va faire
ce que  le Professeur Hermann Touo
m’a appris
lors des cours de méthodes
des Sciences sociales,
lorsque j’étais
à l’Université de Ngaoundéré.
Et pendant ses cours, il aimait dire :
« Les choses en elles-mêmes
m’ont instruites.
Elles ne m’ont point apprises à mentir »
Et nous allons plonger
notre regard dans notre société
pour nous rendre compte qu’en fait,
qu’on soit pour ou contre,
content ou fâché, nous avons tous
mis la femme à la cuisine.
Si les trois régions septentrionales
ont été placées
en zone d’éducation prioritaire
par le Gouvernement camerounais,
c’est bien parce que la jeune Sahélienne
peine à accéder à l’éducation,
est envoyée en mariage très tôt,
et lorsqu’elle parvient même
à traverser tous ces obstacles,
les pressions sociales ont
tout fait pour la tirer vers le bas.
Maintenant ainsi le statu quo ante
et continuant à la fragiliser.
Les pressions qu’elle subit
sont psychologiques, émotionnelles
et même parfois physiques.
Ces pressions sont du fait de ses frères,
de ses proches et de notre silence,
à moi,
à vous,
ce silence complice
et même parfois apeuré,
ne fait que perpétuer la déshumanisation
des êtres fragilisés qui sont relégués
au second, septième, quinzième,
voire vingtième plan de la vie en société.
La femme sahélienne est invisible
dans une société régie
par des règles ultra patriarcales.
Elle semble…
Elle est peu perceptible, semble t-il.
Elle pèse peu
dans la balance de la jouissance
des opportunités économiques,
institutionnelles, voire même humaines.
Parce que la femme n’a pas droit
à l’héritage de son père décédé.
Pourquoi ?
(en fufuldé)
La jeune fille est appelée à se marier
et donc, comme telle,
elle appartient à son mari
qui devient le nouveau maître
de ce qu’elle est et de ce qu’elle a.
Ce qui fait donc que,
une fois le père décédé,
elle n’a accès qu’à des biens mobiliers,
mais pas immobiliers ou du moins rarement.
Vous la verrez rarement hériter
des terres ou des immeubles.
Ceci pour que les biens de la famille,
bien sûr, ne se dispersent pas.
La place de la femme,
nous l’avons mise à la cuisine
et cela est perceptible
même dans l’entrepreneuriat
et le petit commerce.
Un petit tour dans les petits marchés
de Djamboutou ou de Ouro Labo
ou de Djéfatou ou de Ngong,
où j’habite.
Vous verrez qu’il y a beaucoup de femmes
en avant dans les activités commerciales.
C’est elles qui vendent,
qui achètent, qui revendent
des produits
de l’agriculture, de l’élevage
ou encore, pour ceux
qui aiment bien boire,
les activités brassicoles comme du bilbil,
du boyero des gens de Poli
ou encore du poto poto.
Mais malheureusement,
elles ne bénéficient
que très peu de l’avantage
de cette activité économique.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que sans plan
d’investissement à long terme,
elles utilisent cet argent juste
pour les besoins quotidiens du ménage.
Et ça, c’est quand le bon monsieur,
le petit ami, le mari ou le papa,
ne s’accapare pas du gain
si durement gagné.
La place de la femme,
c’est à la cuisine, parce que,
même en ce qui concerne l’éducation,
vous verrez qu’en général,
au Cameroun, le taux de scolarisation
de la jeune fille est bas.
Mais les trois régions septentrionales
ont environ treize points à rattraper
et elles sont au fond du classement,
selon une étude du BUCREP.
Les jeunes filles,
vous les verrez de moins en moins
plus on augmente le niveau.
Si elles sont nombreuses en Sil,
en Sixième, en Terminale, à l’université.
Donc, elles quittent progressivement
les salles de classe pour…
les salles d’accouchement
ou les salles de cuisine,
comme on le dit souvent.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu’on dit chez nous :
(en  fufuldé)
« La jeune fille qui part à l’école
est peu respectueuse de son mari.
Donc, il faut essayer d’enlever ça. »
La mise à l’écart de la femme
est aussi perceptible en politique.
Vous les verrez nombreuses,
c’est elles qui donnent d’ailleurs,
du fait de leur poids statistique,
la légitimité des décideurs élus
sur le plan politique.
Mais, elles ne sont bonnes qu’à décorer.
Elles ne sont bonnes
qu’à arranger l’endroit et aussi à...
(Applaudissements et cris)
…à acclamer et à chanter
pendant les meetings politiques
alors qu’elles-mêmes sont très peu élues.
Regardez un peu l’Assemblée nationale
du Cameroun ou bien les communes,
vous verrez combien de femmes sont maires,
combien de femmes sont députées.
Quelqu’un m’a dit récemment que :
« Bertrand, l’histoire
que tu engages là, va te dépasser
parce que nous, les Africains,
on sait que les femmes sont faites
pour préparer et non pour décider. »
Erreur.
Vous savez, il y a de cela
beaucoup des siècles,
je n’étais pas né, vous non plus, ni votre
grand-père, ni votre arrière grand-père.
Dans un empire très célèbre,
celui du grand roi Soundiata Keïta,
qui le connaît ici ?
Soundiata Keïta, dans son empire,
a édicté la toute première charte
d’une des toutes premières chartes
des droits de l’homme qui s’appelait :
la Charte du Manden.
Et rassurez vous, les dispositions
étaient très intéressantes
en termes de droits de l’homme
et consorts.
Mais, il y a beaucoup de dispositions
à l’intérieur qui parlent
de comment nous devons traiter les femmes
et même les placer dans la société.
Et cet article seize nous dit que,
en plus de leurs occupations quotidiennes,
les femmes doivent être associées
à tous nos Gouvernements.
C’est-à-dire que,
si Aïssatou balaie et lave
ou même prépare pour vous, monsieur,
vous devez l’associer
à votre Gouvernement,
c’est-à-dire aux décisions quotidiennes
de la vie du foyer et même du quartier
et pourquoi pas, de la ville et du pays.
Quelqu’un va me dire,
en terme de recherche scientifique,
il faut deux preuves qu’une, parce que
une preuve est facilement cassable.
Maintenant, nous revenons plus près
avec l’hymne du Wassoulou du célèbre
Almamy Samory Touré,
qui a un peu avant le 19ᵉ siècle,
étendu son empire
à force de batailles,
et aussi de razzias.
C’était un chef de guerre
intelligent, futé et perspicace.
Dans l’hymne qui lui est dédié,
l’hymne de son royaume, de son empire,
on demande à ce valeureux guerrier
si à un moment,
il a peur de braver l’ennemi,
il peut prêter son sabre aux femmes
qui lui indiqueront
le chemin de l’honneur.
(Applaudissements)
Quelqu’un va me dire : « Non, Bertrand,
tu déranges. Ce sont les textes anciens. »
Mais la vérité c’est que,
notre essence en tant qu’Africains,
nous condamne ou bien nous oblige
ou nous exige à respecter la femme
et à la déplacer de l’arrière-scène
où on veut la cacher
pour l’exposer comme un bijou
sur la couronne du développement.
(Applaudissements)
Ceux qui ont dit et qui ont acquiescé
que la place de la femme est à la cuisine,
c’est parce que justement,
ils voulaient la cacher
et l’exclure du salon qui, semble-t-il,
est le lieu où les décisions se prennent,
oubliant que parfois, il y a la chambre.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Mais, cette exclusion des salons
ou bien des arbres à palabres,
n’est pas pour notre bien.
Pourquoi ? Parce que,
dit-on, la nuit porte conseil.
Est-ce-que la nuit a une bouche
pour parler à votre oreille ?
Non.
C’est la femme, votre épouse, votre sœur,
qui va vous murmurer la solution
à ce problème perspicace
qui vous dérange.
(Applaudissements)
Et, je voudrais dire
que s’il a été dit
que la place de la femme,
c’est à la cuisine, moi, je suis d’accord.
Oui, la place de la femme,
c’est à la cuisine,
mais, à la cuisine interne
du développement.
(Acclamations)
(Applaudissements)
Pourquoi je le dis ?
Parce que, donnez peu à une femme,
elle vous donnera beaucoup.
Donnez dix francs à une maman chaque jour,
voyez comment elle va élever une fratrie
de dix enfants pendant plus de cinq ans.
Ça a été le cas dans ma famille.
(Applaudissements)
Pourquoi ? Donnez un rêve
à Gaëlle Bella Mbom,
elle vous fera un TEDx event ici à Garoua
pour la première fois dans le Septentrion.
(Acclamations)
(Applaudissements)
Pourquoi ? Donnez à Louise Lokumu
un peu d’espace
et vous verrez comment
le Grand Nord sera reverdi.
Oui, la place de la femme, c’est
à la cuisine interne du développement
et il est temps que nos décideurs
se décident à les placer au centre
dans les politiques du développement
que nous cherchons tant
parce que, la solution africaine
au développement, à mon avis, se trouve
dans les mains et dans le cœur des femmes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
(Musique)